So, you just learned how to do poi
meltdowns and you want to learn how to
move around with them, how to flow with
them, how to make them look awesome.
Well, I'm here to help out. I have
options that will help you travel across
the stage. I have options that will get
you leaping with joy.
And I've got options that are going to
make you go off into space in ways that
you couldn't imagine. So, let's dive in.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm going to
give you three options for how you can
dance and flow up those poi meltdowns.
But before we dive in, I just want to
give a quick shout out to the friends of
the channel. Big thanks go to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer
Light Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to
make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these amazing companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video. And just to put a massive
thank you out there to Pekka Beckonin
for having supported this channel for so
very long. I appreciate you and
everything that you've done these past
few years. PO meltdowns. In my mind,
they are one of the more advanced
applications for the PO techniques that
involve working with hip reels and also
getting into the realm of behind the
back tricks. When we play around with
meltdowns, not only are we reaching
behind our backs, but we're also
reaching all the way across our bodies.
And the good news is, because they add
so much body movement, they also give us
plenty of options to dance with. And I
have specifically cobbled together three
dance steps from the ballet world that
happen to be a perfect fit for po
meltdowns. And if you don't already know
how to do meltdowns, you're in luck
because I did a tutorial on them that I
will go ahead and link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
So our first option is something called
iglissad, which is French for glide. And
it involves jumping from side to side of
the stage. The footwork for this looks a
little complicated. It's not nearly as
bad as you think. You start with your
feet together. The whole idea is you
want to get up in the air with your feet
spread out and then bring them back
together when you land on the other
side. You leap out to your right. You
leap out to your left, to your right, to
your left, like so. And this just
happens to work perfectly with a
meltdown because meltdowns already have
sections where you turn your whole body
to the right and then turn your whole
body to the left, to the right, to the
left. So when you're coming from your
left here, you want to open up. Boom.
And that's your jump over to the right.
When you reset here, going back to the
original side, you can take another leap
back to the left. So we leap right, we
leap left. Right. We leap left, over,
back and forth. Bonus points if you can
give me a huge extension as you're
taking that glead to your stage right
here.
Beautiful. Option number two, something
called a potter beret. Basically, you
can take the meltdown and travel back
and forth across the stage. Pa beret
breaks down like this. Essentially, you
start with your feet together. You're
going to cross one in front of the
other. You're gonna open up. And you're
gonna cross that same foot behind the
other and open up. You could also start
with the step back and open, forward,
and open. Now, you notice whether I'm
stepping back and open, forward, open,
or forward, open, back, open. Something
that this has in common with the
meltdown. My hips are turning from side
to side. So, we can actually match this
up with the movement of the meltdown
here. I like to take my left hand behind
as my left foot goes behind. Open up as
my feet come to either side and then
cross my foot in front my left foot in
front of my right as my right hand goes
behind. And then reset. I can then take
it back where I step back with my right
as my right hand goes behind. I can open
up as I step out with my left and then
take my right in front of my left to
finish things up over on stage left. So
you want to think step back open forward
to one side. Step back open forward to
the other side. Back open forward. Good.
Back, open, forward. We're good. This is
going to take you all over the stage and
it will make that meltdown look so
freaking cool because nobody else uses
the stage like this. All right, and if
you are ready for our final and greatest
challenge of this video, we're going to
play around with something called a
barrel roll. So, barrel rolls are a fun
technique that you can practice. uh get
down in a little pla here and kind of
rock your body back and forth like this.
And you're going to head on over to your
stage right here. As I come down on my
right leg, I'm going to jump and bring
my entire body around in such a way that
I want to look up at the sky as I carry
over here. So go once, twice, and third
time look up at the sky and then land.
Um, if you want to, you can practice
this with like a table or a friend who
is like sitting on all fours. You can
just roll your back over them to get a
feel for this. But ultimately, you want
to get to a point where you feel
comfortable driving your body over
kind of like a barrel. The name makes
sense. So, how do we get this to work
with a meltdown? I'm so glad you asked.
It's all in that extension moment here
when we're coming from left hand behind
to open. What I want to do is I can take
that pa moment. Boom. And take it over
top. So I can go over and the trick is
when I land, I got to get that right
hand behind my back to finish it up.
I'm not going to lie, there's not a good
way to reset from this. There's not a
good way to get back over to stage left.
This is kind of a one-way street, but my
goodness, does it look cool, right?
Maybe you can combine this together with
the potter of beret. Maybe you can say,
"Stay over on stage left here. Go on in.
Take your barrel roll and take your pod
beret back. Take your barrel roll and
take that pod beret back." Great combo
that uses the same trick. And just as a
special bonus, I figured I would give
you a little bit of jazz technique
because that's more my forte. And this
is just a classic step touch in uh in
jazz. You step, touch, you step, touch,
you step, touch, you step, touch.
Whichever foot is doing the touch,
you're just tapping down on the ground.
You do not commit weight to it. You just
touch, and then move it back for the
next step. Touch, move it back for the
next step. The trick here is as you're
doing this back and forth, I would also
love to see boom, a little bit of hip
involved because you have just like a
half a second to work with on either end
of this pattern. This is something that
kind of feels a little bit Bob FSY to
me. You may find that it's a good way to
make those meltdowns look just a little
bit sassier. Either way, it's a winner.
So, give it a try. So, those are my
picks for three different ballet steps
that work great with meltdowns. Did I
miss something that you do with your
meltdowns? Please leave me a comment and
let me know. I'd love to find out. In
the meantime, if you wouldn't mind
giving this video a like, a share, a
subscribe, that would help other people
find this video, and more importantly,
it would help my channel grow. So, help
me out, please. And thank you.
So once again friends, I just have to
put a huge thank you out there to the
lovely and talented Jennifer Ever
Swanson for doing the camera work on
this one and also coaching me through on
how to clean up my glee sods. Thank you
so much for all your support. This video
would not exist without you. Thank you,
Ever. Thank you.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you. You all
rock. And if you out there watching are
not currently a supporter, but you'd
like to become one, the way you can do
that is heading on over to my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. There you can get access
to a whole host of rewards including
getting your name in the credits as well
as access to an exclusive weekly lesson
as part of the flow circle. I'll go
ahead and include a link to that down in
the description as well as up in the
cards. Go check it out, please and thank
you. And if the dance terminology that
I'm throwing out there maybe feels a
little bit overwhelming, I did a few
video tutorials last year on some basic
dance steps combined with poi that I'll
go ahead and include a link to as a
playlist down in the description as well
as up on screen. Thank you so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care.